New Jersey Governor Chris Christie
marked the second anniversary of
Hurricane sandy
that took place this week by getting it
into it with a heckler two years now
yeah the this man interrupted a Christie
speech to protest what he called the
slow pace of rebuilding here's what
Christie said in response if we're gonna
get into a debate here today it's gonna
get very interesting and very fun
there's somebody like you who doesn't
know a damn thing about what you're
talking about except to stand up and
show off when the cameras are here I've
been here when the cameras aren't here
buddy and done the work so listen you
want to have the conversation later I'm
happy to have it buddy but until that
time sit down and shut up
I don't know that Saturday night was he
running for office there I think he was
this is why he's so popular this is
distilled ed he's so good at channeling
that and this is why it's popular it has
nothing but to do with policy that's
nothing to his record as governor well
ed to your point that heckler actually
invited Chris Christie to dinner
afterwards
seriously Brendan to your point he's as
much playing for Iowa there yeah of
course he is for New Jersey of course
and this is what I mean this is he
became popular through YouTube videos of
this these kinds of performances he
shouted down a teacher once at a union
meeting yeah fifteen will this fly in
the Midwest and we did that really does
the jersey attitude will this fly is
soaring in the Midwest I in 2012 I went
to a meeting of Republican lawmakers
from them from from at the state level
and they were desperate for Christie to
run that was the cry where's Christie
that was you know that was already in
the last election cycle he's so good at
this I think it plays he's so good at it
that again the man invited chris
Christie to dinner and chris Christie's
is response classic is there about a
thousand things I can do tonight and
going to dinner with you is about 1000
if he doesn't run put them on the Fed
ten minutes in that's already a quote of
the day fresh